I never thought I'd ask this but here it
goes where is a OC the socialist
congresswoman from Westchester has
disappeared faster than a Clinton enemy
on suicide watch we will examine where
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez went and what
it means for the Democratic Party then
President Trump gets promoted from
president to chosen one we will examine
the difference between humility and
modesty Gillette gets woke and goes
broke we look at what it means for
corporations and politicians finally the
mailbag all that more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show I can't believe I'm asking it but
where is a OC where I never thought I
would say that question you don't know
what you've got till it's gone a OC
she's gone
where is she for two years AOC has been
the dominant personality in the news
second only I guess to President Trump
and in certain news cycles she's
dominated the news even more than
President Trump then three weeks ago she
fired her chief of staff a guy named
psychic chug Rob Artie and now she has
vanished from the face of the earth at
least she's vanished from Twitter and
from the news headlines this fuels a
conspiracy theory that has been going on
since March
I say conspiracy theory by the way now
in quotes because now we know that the
fluoride in the water might be hurting
people we know that the frogs actually
are turning gay we're supposed to
believe that Jeffrey Epstein killed
himself on suicide watch so I think
we're all Alex Jones at this point and
the conspiracy if there is just our
reality this particular so-called
conspiracy theory was put forward back
in March by a guy named mr. Reagan who
has a popular YouTube channel and the
theory is that a OSI is not really a
conviction politician who's now in
Congress
she's an actress who was cast by
progressive Democrats to play a
congressional candidate then she won and
now she's sort of acting out the role of
a congresswoman here is the theory from
mr. Reagan
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez is not really
the congresswoman of New York's fort
teemed congressional district she is
essentially an actress she's merely
playing the part of a New York
congresswoman I know this sounds crazy
but bear with me in 2017 a group called
the Justice Democrats held auditions for
potential congressional candidates that
they would run on their platform for
various congressional seats throughout
the country
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez's brother
Gabriel submitted her for the role
now I didn't have to go digging for
evidence for this because they freely
admit it they brag about it back in 2016
we put out a call for nominations we got
over 10,000 nominations out of those
10,000 nominations we found Alexandria
my brother told me that he had sent my
nomination in the summer but I was like
literally working out of a restaurant
then I was like there's no way so this
tells you not just the conspiracy theory
but what's happened over the last three
weeks this tells you a lot about a OC in
the left-wing media the left generally
the way that they treat conspiracy
theories and the real conspiracy what
does it mean for AOC and the Democrats
we'll get to that in one second but
first I have to thank our good friends
over at NetSuite because a gigantic
problem that growing businesses have is
they can't keep track of all of their
numbers they've got this hodgepodge of
business systems so one piece of
software is handling one area of your
business another piece is handling
another another one over here and they
don't know how to talk to each other and
you can't keep track of your numbers and
it loses you money and it loses you time
which by the way is money I've been
involved in a number of growing
businesses obviously this one I was at
The Daily wire back when it was you know
three people sitting on the stoop over
in LA and then it's become this big
business I've been involved in other
businesses as well and one thing I could
say in every one of those cases is I
wish earlier on we had prioritized on
getting a handle on our numbers now you
can do that with NetSuite
by Oracle the business management
software that handles every aspect of
your business in an easy-to-use cloud
platform gives you the visibility and
control that you need to grow you save
time you save money you save unneeded
headaches because especially early on in
a business when you get a little
later on in a business you can afford to
make a few more mistakes early on you
can't afford to make mistakes and by the
way even as businesses grow the more you
allow mistakes to be made the greater
chance you have of taking the whole
thing down and those mistakes happen
because you just can't keep track of
everything
NetSuite allows you to handle sales
finance accounting orders HR instantly
right from your desktop or phone that's
why NetSuite is the world's number one
cloud business system right now NetSuite
is offering you valuable insights with a
free guide seven key strategies to grow
your profits at NetSuite comm / Knowles
that is n etsu ite dot-com / Knowles
canna wles go there right now there is
no reason not to you can get your free
guide seven key strategies to grow your
profits download it read it I am Telling
You you will not regret it NetSuite comm
/ Knowles canna wles
now this conspiracy theory is so called
about aoc for mr. Regan is really not
much of a conspiracy theory what does it
say it says the Justice Democrats a
radical left-wing progressive group
recruited candidates to run we know that
happens they admit that we know that
Alexandria cassio cortezes brother sent
in her tape nominated her to be cast by
this organization we know that's true a
OC told us it was true we know that the
Justice Democrats picked her because
they ran her campaign we know that they
ran her campaign because then she
nominated and appointed the head of the
Justice Democrats the co-founder of its
psychic Agri party to be her chief of
staff it later came out by the way that
this guy psychic checker Barty had
embezzled nearly a million dollars from
the campaign and funneled it to his own
businesses for his own uses but then the
way that we know that the so-called
conspiracy theory is true that basically
these progressive operatives found a
empty-headed Congress or an empty-headed
bartender rather and turned her into a
congresswoman and filled her with their
ideas the way we know that that is very
likely true is when she fired the head
of the Justice Democrats as her chief of
staff she disappeared the magic was gone
because apparently he was the brains
behind the operation I don't even think
I can get
that without laughing a little bit
because I said the brains behind AOC
which is a contradiction in terms but
she really did have a great deal of
cleverness a real savvy for the media
that appears to have disappeared
immediately when that guy was fired so
what can we learn most importantly it
kind of puts the kibosh on conspiracies
and conspiracy theories and this is
important for a week that we've learned
that fluoride in the water hurts people
we have known for a while now that the
frickin frogs are turning gay they're
actually turning a transgender and and
this a assi incident what this shows is
that yes there are puppet-masters for
puppets AOC may very well be a Charlie
McCarthy dollar little marionette who's
got it getting her puppet strings pulled
by more intelligent and more
ideologically formed left wingers like
psychic Agri Party and the Justice
Democrats however once the puppets get
into power they have the power so the
Justice Democrats they were the puppet
masters they were running the whole show
and AOC was just there like blah blah
blah green New Deal blah blah blah and
she was just parroting whatever they
wanted her to say but now she's the
congresswoman and now she is in control
and now she can fire the Justice
Democrats and it might hurt her it might
be a bad political decision but she now
has the control the puppet has become
the puppet master and I say it might be
a bad political decision might be a
brilliant political decision because she
had all that heat on her I mean she was
saying a lot of things getting a lot of
attention dominating the conversation
but if she wasn't doing what she wanted
to do if she if it wasn't serving her
political interests then it was
absolutely right
to fire them there might have come a
point when the political interests of
the Justice Democrats and the political
interests of aoc diverge and at that
point she's gonna look out for number
one the second thing that this shows is
that the leftist media is just
completely dishonest and in the leftist
media I'm including the so-called fact
checkers snopes.com the fact checker had
a an article said quote is rep
Alexandria Cassio Cortez and
actress playing a congresswoman false
this is totally false and what's so
dishonest about that is I guess that
that line could be false is she an
actress playing a congresswoman
technically by definition that's false
because she is now a congresswoman but
if the point of that article is supposed
to be was she simply cast in this role
by justice Democrats who ran everything
that she was doing up until very
recently and that is obviously true she
has admitted the beds true that just as
Democrats have admitted that that's true
we've all seen it with our own eyes but
the media just can't give you that
reality it doesn't go along with their
narrative so they put out an article
that is 99.9% a lie in order to serve
their narrative and then the third thing
that this shows this is the most
difficult part the left is the left is
much harder to defeat than just one or
two politicians we think you know you
see a OC or Ilhan Omar or Rashida to
leave or somebody like that you think I
really don't like that person if I just
get them out of Congress then the
country will be better when it comes to
the left they don't really matter that
much those individual people the left
and the right have different approaches
to politics and we have different
political apparatus if you take out one
of the right-wing political stars you
have seriously damaged the right if you
take out a left-wing political star you
haven't because the left operates in a
much more institutional way than the
right does the right is much more
individually focused we have we have our
star politicians obviously we have Trump
for instance we have our star media
figures then we have a handful of think
tanks and that's it that's our political
apparatus in the country it's pretty
much just these individual personalities
for the left it's much more
institutionalized they have some star
politicians that's true they actually
don't have very many star media figures
they don't have a Rush Limbaugh they
don't have a Sean Hannity they don't
have a Tucker chorus and they have a few
smaller media figures on MSNBC like
Rachel Maddow for instance that's my
second job obviously is I put my Warby
Parker glasses on I go to
over to MSNBC because I need a second
income but their ratings are very low
over there at MSNBC and the same thing
is true on they don't really have radio
they tried to do left wing talk radio it
totally failed what they have instead of
media stars is they have media quote
unquote watchdog media operative groups
whose purpose is not to put out their
own content but to get the right-wing
content fired because we rely on media
personalities on the right and so they
have groups like Media Matters and
others whose whole job it is is to watch
our shows and then try to get us fired
and try to get our advertisers boycotted
so they've got that then they've also
got the countless astroturf operative
organizations such as the Justice
Democrats because AOC can rise and fall
but the Justice Democrats are gonna
stick around the individual politicians
can rise and fall but the George Soros
open society foundation network that is
that funds all of these left-wing
astroturf groups they're not grassroots
groups they're not organic
they are astroturfed in from above those
are gonna stick around and those are
much more difficult to defeat the that
is a different approach to politics
maybe the right needs to become a little
bit more institutional you know the left
learn this lesson 50 years ago they they
took on what they called the long march
through the institution's so they've
hollowed out the universities most
notably they've hollowed out the news
media they've hollowed out Hollywood
wasn't always that way Hollywood used to
make good movies wasn't always making
radical leftist movies it's just
basically just the last 50 years or so
that they really went hardcore and the
advantage to that strategy it's not as
glamorous it's not as sexy it takes a
long time but then you've got it if
you've got Hollywood then you've got the
biggest cultural microphone if you've
got the universities then you are
shaping the minds of the entire next
generation the right needs to move into
that it's good to have our stars it's
good to have our Trump but we have got
to establish that institutional presence
or else we are at the mercy of and and
we're at the whims of fortune and we're
at the mercy of the the left and were
the whims of the left so AOC might come
back I hope she does I miss her I can't
do I miss
I miss reading about her I missed the
stupid things she would say that we
could then all make fun of but there's
gonna be another AOC because the
organization the put a OC in power ain't
going away the New York Times admitted
this the New York Times had a headline
back in February that said the I
paraphrasing the headline was something
to the effect of the Justice Democrats
helped AOC get elected they've already
got their eyes on other candidates
there's going to be another C AOC that
pops up and we've got to be able to
match that strategy now enough about
Congress enough about the Democrats
we've got to talk about our own star
politician president Trump who just got
promoted to the king of Israel which is
this by the way this is being totally
obviously misconstrued by the left
intentionally but even some
conservatives are whining and crying and
clutching their pearls we'll get to what
was bad about Trump's comments we'll get
to what that actually means and we'll
put it into context of modesty and
humility but first I got to thank our
pals over at ring rings mission is to
make neighborhoods safer and they're
doing just that
protecting millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home from anywhere so if you've got a
surprise visitor let's say it's a
delivery man you want to talk to the
delivery guy you've got to weigh video
and audio features you can be either in
your home in your bedroom or at the
office or on a beach and you can say hey
pal leave the package right over there
let's say you've got a burglar coming up
you've got a weirdo a bad guy this
happened to my producer Jonathan hey
just a few months ago he had some wackos
in the middle of the night he talked to
them on his - way through the doorbell
at 3:00 in the morning from his bedroom
and then of course they scampered away
let's say it's your mother-in-law you
can see that she's there and you can go
completely silent turn off all the
lights and pretend that you're not home
don't move if you don't move she can't
see you that is the kind of value that
you can get from a ring device it's
incredible it makes all of us feel safer
I love it I travel a lot
sweet little Elise is a pretty good shot
she's good with a gun but you don't want
to put her in that situation I feel
safer because of ring I give out ring as
a housewarming gift now to all my
friends when they buy homes one because
it's an incredible gift it makes you
feel like you're in the future makes you
feel like you're in the Jetsons and it
really keeps you safe and two the reason
I give it out
a gift is it's not that expensive it's
an incredible value so I look like a
really cool guy and I don't have to
shell out a ton of money as a listener
you have a special offer on a ring
starter kit available right now with a
video doorbell and motion-activated
floodlight camera the starter kit has
everything you need to start building a
ring of security around your home go to
ring.com slash knowles kano wles do it
right now
you will feel safe and you will feel
very very cool ring.com / Knowles Kenna
wles speaking of feeling safe I feel so
much safer now that our president is not
only the duly elected president of the
United States but he is the king of
Israel and apparently the chosen one
brought to bring balance to the force
that is because of a story that came out
from a radio talk-show host that
President Trump then of course retweeted
because he couldn't help himself in this
whole hubbub we'll talk about the hubbub
but the main takeaway from it I find
that people always misunderstand is the
difference between humility and modesty
the difference between false modesty
which we have a lot of in this culture
and true humility which we don't have a
lot of so yesterday king of Israel
Second Coming and Antichrist were
trending on Twitter this was not because
we were in the end times it's because
President Trump tweeted something which
to the left is the end time so they
can't tell the difference between those
two Trump tweeted out a compliment from
the radio host Wayne Allyn root in which
root praised President Trump in a really
some might say hyperbolic way and
alluded to him as the king of Israel and
the second coming of God here is Wayne
Allyn root don't forget I don't if you
haven't watched the show Apple to be
Jewish by birth and 75% of all Jews vote
Democrat and they don't like Trump and
this is the greatest present for Jews
and for Israel in the history of the
world not just America Trump's the best
president for Israel in the history of
the world and the Jewish people love him
like he's the king of Israel they love
him like he is the second coming of God
and in America American Jews don't like
them okay
so there's one big issue before we get
to the theological issues before we get
even to the political issues there is
just one one thing he said that doesn't
strike very strongly which is the Jews
can't think that Trump is the second
coming of God because the Jews don't
think the first coming of God has
happened yet so just from a very
technical semantic point it cannot be
the case that they think of Trump as the
second coming the political point that
this guy is trying to make is correct
Israel really likes Trump this is
undeniable Israel named an entire town
after President Trump and Israel also
named an important train station after
President Trump president Trump moved
the embassy finally in Israel from Tel
Aviv to Jerusalem was have been US
policy for over 20 years and Trump was
the first president with the guts to
actually do it Bibi Netanyahu Prime
Minister basically campaigned on how he
was friends with President Trump he's
Trump has been better for Israel than
any president in US history and his
daughter is a convert to Judaism and her
husband her Jewish husband is a senior
adviser to the president so he is a good
president for Jews and a good president
for Israel now the the theological point
somehow managed to offend both Jews and
Christians it offended Protestants and
Catholics it really really brought
people together obviously the Jews don't
think he's the second coming cuz they're
waiting on the first coming still they
don't they don't realize that it already
happened and also much as we now
speaking from the Christian perspective
much as we conservative Catholics and
Protestants love President Trump
comparing him to Christ is a bridge too
far even for me it's a bridge too far
you know we like comparing him to Cyrus
or David or Sampson I personally see
Trump is a sort of Samson figure in the
Bible Christ comparisons still quite
frowned upon
not great somehow manages to offend Jews
and Christians king of Israel is fine
king of Jews not not fine king of Israel
is great though I really like this idea
because
President Trump is about to become the
Conan gur of Greenland that's the Old
Norse word for King Conan gur that's
what he's gonna be after the shock and
awe campaign where we finally take
Greenland back so I like the king of his
real idea but I want to put this in
context if Barack Obama had done this if
he had retweeted some radio host saying
all these things about him we would have
totally freaked out about it because we
all suspected Barack Obama was the
Antichrist or close to it and we would
have freaked out about it that's that's
not evidence of hypocrisy politics is
about context politics is about
circumstance politics does not live in
sum total abstraction in the air
politics is about what's really
happening in real time to real people
the difference here is that Barack Obama
actually thought he was the chosen one
he really did he actually said that his
election would be the moment that the
planet began to heal he said that the
sea levels would begin to reduce like
he's Moses parting the Red Sea he talked
about calming the oceans he really
thought he was the chosen one
Trump is joking he is there is evidence
that he's joking here's the evidence
after this whole blow-up Trump was asked
a completely unrelated question about
his China trade war and he joked about
the whole hubbub of king of Israel and
everything by alluding to himself
completely out of context as the chosen
one over the last five or six years
China's made 500 billion dollars five
hundred billion ripped it out of the
United States and not only that if you
take a look intellectual property theft
add that to it and they had a lot of
other things do it so somebody excuse me
somebody had to do it I am the chosen
one
somebody had to do it so I'm taking on
China
I'm taking on China on trade and you
know what we're winning I love this guy
because he this is the evidence that he
knows it's a joke because he immediately
makes a joke about it if if Donald Trump
really believed what the radio host was
saying if you really believe that he's
the king of Israel
it's
incoming of God or he's perceived as the
second coming of God in the chosen one
then he would treat that seriously
instead of immediately making a joke
about it because he's talking about the
China trade war and by the way he's
right about the China trade war you know
politicians and presidents of both
parties kicked that can down the road
for eighteen years after China entered
the WTO the World Trade Organization in
2001 the troubles really began in
earnest they were illegally devaluing
their currency they were illegally
subsidizing steel and aluminum they were
illegally stealing our property they
were illegally forcing American
businesses to work with local banks
which was really just a secret tax they
were illegally spying us they were doing
all sorts of stuff challenging our
interests in the region and we did
nothing because we just we got so hooked
on cheap electronics that we didn't want
to stop that from coming they were
stealing our jobs and if not just in the
regular flow of goods and services from
country to country they were stealing
our jobs by cheating on trade and this
was acknowledged by both parties
President Trump and Chuck Schumer Chuck
Schumer even recently said President
Trump
don't go weak with China because someone
has to take it on so he's saying I'm the
guy I'm the guy the buck up has to me
I'm gonna take it on why I guess I'm the
chosen one yeah that's why and he's
looking up at the sky right he's he's
joking about it this is the difference
between humility and false modesty Trump
has an ego nobody is denying that he
puts his name on all the buildings
anyone who's in politics or anyone who's
in TV has an ego but at least he's got a
sense of humor about it he talked about
how he doesn't drink a little while ago
he was he said I think I'm the only
president who's never had a beer that's
actually my only good quality could you
imagine if I had had a beer if I were a
drunk I'd be the worst that's how he
sees jokey he says my only good quality
is I don't have a drink
he's self-aware he knows how he comes
off he quotes a guy calling him the
second coming because it's funny and
then he jokes about it cuz it's funny
Trump has no false modesty I don't think
he has any modesty whatsoever not saying
he's got any modesty but he does exhibit
pretty regularly a certain
humility conservatives generally have
humility by definition you need a
humility to be a conservative because to
be a conservatives to acknowledge the
human nature is broken it's fallen it's
imperfect and imperfecta boleyn that
means there's a limit to what politics
can accomplish the left doesn't have
that false modesty her little left
rather doesn't have that humility what
they do have is false modesty Barack
Obama was all false modesty the guy had
no humility he never did any self
effacing jokes he never could take a
joke he never could doubt his own
abilities or the possibilities of
politics he was heading toward utopia he
was going to make the sea levels reduce
not as if he wasn't joking about it he
really thought that we are the ones
we've been waiting for this religious
language presenting himself as the
Messiah this is true pride this is this
is people who can't laugh at themselves
beware of people who cannot laugh at
themselves GK Chesterton said this he
said the angels can fly because they can
take themselves lightly not that they
always take themselves lightly but they
can PB beware people who can't tell a
self-effacing joke or take a self
effacing joke that is pride that the
difference here is key and that
difference can even make the king of
Israel humble speaking of laughing we
have to get to this this stupid Jillette
a dime een there's so much more to get
to but we have got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube head on over to
daily wire the daily wire has turned
four years old and we are thrilled about
that as a thank you to our fans we are
giving away one month of our premium
monthly subscription to anyone who uses
decode birthday that is right for all of
August and August is winding down as we
celebrate this milestone we are giving
away a free first month for new premium
monthly subscribers just use the code
birthday and come join in on the fun and
thank you to everybody who has
subscribed and who's tuned in and has
helped us made it make it to four years
I really appreciate it
we'll be right back we got to talk about
you let get and woke and go and broke
then we got to get to the mailbag go to
daily wire calm we'll be right back
Gillette got woke about seven months ago
seven months ago Gillette launched an ad
against toxic masculinity Gillette a
razor company for men that's what they
do they sell ads to men decided to
launch an ad about how terrible men are
here's just a little snippet of it
making the same old excuses so you may
have a conversation about this ad in
your workplace or among your friends
today it's certainly getting a lot of
attention online it's an ad from
Gillette just out so this ad goes on and
talks boys will be boys how awful men
are how terrible they're grabbing women
they're so awful and then Gillette got
woke and now the men are gonna be better
be the best a man can be be better and
it had all the PC stuff in it like for
instance all the bad guys in the
beginning virtually all of them are
white guys and then after when she get
to the good guys virtually all that good
guys are not white guys and they're just
totally leaning in to the politics of
race and the politics of gender and the
politics of leftism they didn't just
stop there they followed with an ad
about fat acceptance and then they they
followed with an ad about a guy teaching
his daughter to shave her face after she
decided to pretend to be a man here's
the Gillette transgender ad growing up I
was always trying to figure out what
kind of man I wanted to become and I'm
still trying to figure out what kind of
man that I want to become I always knew
I was different I didn't know that there
was a term for the type of person that I
was I went into my transition just
wanting to be happy I'm glad I am at the
point where I'm able to shave south so
North nor
east-west never in a hurry right
okay so this is a bad as woke as you can
get we're a company that sells men's
razors is now telling girls to shave to
think that they're boys Gillette has
decided now to change course seven
months later they have quote decided to
shift the spotlight from social issues
to local heroes well why is that it's
basically saying we've decided to shift
the focus 180 degrees from what we've
been doing which is failing to what we
should have been what we had been doing
before then what we should be doing
again why because there's information
out that Gillette's parent company
Procter and Gamble
took an eight billion dollar write down
for the brand since that ad aired eight
billion with Abby because they've
alienated their whole customer base this
is their problem there's an important
lesson here to be learned not just for
corporations but for politicians and for
all of us some companies survive going
woke Nike went woke but they decided
that their their whole base was
basically going to be people who are
open to race racial politics
particularly in urban areas particularly
people who are leftist and that seemed
to work well enough for them with Colin
Kapernick same is not true of Gillette
or other companies same as not true of
politicians you don't win by insulting
your supporters Democrats have learned
this lesson for fifty years now they've
constantly alienated more and more of
their base that's why they've actually
got to import new voters in the form of
illegal immigration to the tune of a
million a year is because they're
alienating the base of Americans
conservatives do this often to
conservatives many conservatives that
I've seen hate their own supporters and
they are uncomfortable with their
supporters at least or at least they
look down on their supporters these are
the people I call conservative but not
that kind of conservatives I'm a
conservative they're willing to admit
I'm conservative but I'm not that kind
I'm not the kind that's bad please love
me New York Times love me
I hate Trump I hate his tweets no help
me oh no please
I'm clutching my pearls I'm almost gonna
choke my pearls around my neck these are
people were uncomfortable with their own
base we've seen this in some
presidential campaigns it's not a
winning strategy you don't win that way
it's it's not good to do it it's not
moral to do it it's not nice it's not
compact
and politically it's pretty stupid
Gillette is learning that lesson and
hopefully many other conservatives will
learn that lesson as well let's get to
the mailbag before we got to go first
question from Evan dear Michael I need
an answer to a very controversial
question that only you can answer what
is the best place to get pizza in New
York City and what are your favorite
toppings I know that your answer will
get another hit piece on you from Media
Matters thanks Evan there is a correct
answer to this it's a correct answer
that very few people know the answer is
cafe al Mercado
in the meat market by Arthur Avenue in
the Bronx that is the best pizza in New
York it's a little out of the way if
you're in Manhattan you can look you get
pizza pretty good pizza just about
anywhere in New York you want the best
pizza go to Arthur Avenue in the meat
market Cafe el mercado they have great
pizza they got broccoli rabe on it it's
very good for normal pizza that's not as
good
my favorite toppings all the time
sausage and onions a little sweet a
little salty it's by far the best pizza
this is not just my subjective
preference this is objectively true
next question from drew I have a student
who just received a scholarship to Yale
to play football and he's a religious
conservative what advice would you give
him to prepare him for being in that
environment he should join an
organization called the Tory Party which
is one of the constituent parties of the
Yale political union join the Tory party
he'll have a great time actually one of
my good friends from the Tory party got
recruited to Yale to play football he
was a very religious conservative and he
joined the Tory party as one of the
smartest guys I met there do that Yale
is a great place to be if you're a
religious conservative because there
were like four people there who are
religious conservatives but it exposes
you to the best arguments from the other
side the atheists and the leftists and
all of that you get all these arguments
coming in and you really get to hone
your beliefs you get to figure out what
you think and I was I know I'm a member
of the Tory Party an alumnus of it and
that organization in particular really
helped me to hone what I think and talk
to other conservatives and figure out
discarded some old ideas get some other
ideas I left I went into Yale as a
somewhat conservative atheist and I left
believing that God exists and far more
conservatives so I would take advantage
of that opportunity embrace the culture
battle embrace the fact that everyone is
opposed to what you think that can
really be a great advantage from Emma
I'm thirty years old and I've decided
that it's finally time to come out to my
high school friends you're gonna tell
him you're a lesbian right no you're
going to tell them that you're a
conservative she goes on quote politics
has never been a main talking point for
us but with media making politics so
trendy it's been coming up more and more
and I now worry that they will be upset
with me when they find out that I voted
for President Trump and have
conservative values do you have any
suggestions or words of advice on how to
approach this yes be confident and be
funny bigger faster funnier good advice
and show business good advice in
politics when you tell your friends that
you're a conservative let's say you're
all sitting around and they say oh oh oh
this Trump he's so awful he he's gonna
buy Greenland
he wants to buy Greenland he's so
awfully so terrible it's so stupid
that's so bad there are two ways that
you can respond to that if you want to
let people know that you kind of like
Trump and you are a conservative you can
either take this kind of timid nice
moderate Mitt Romney approach and say
well you know you know I don't think
it's a totally bad idea I mean look it's
easy I don't really like his tweets that
much and he really is bad and I am the
ice bad I really don't like him but but
I kind of like them and they're gonna
crush you if you say that because that
that approach is the I'm a conservative
but not that kind of conservative
approach you're timid you don't seem
confident your views you're a little too
earnest you're a little too serious it's
very off-putting and it's gonna have
them pounced on you the alternative to
that is oh I think Trump's hilarious I
think we should totally take Greenland
there's no reason that Denmark that
little tiny country all the ways away
gets to own Greenland I think we should
take it we should build a giant Trump
Tower on Greenland we should make it a
launching site for not only our trade
but for our military I'm all for it
make America Greenland again and if you
take that approach it's hard for them to
respond because you're clobbering them
you're putting them on the defensive and
the best defense is a good offense also
you're funny and it's hard to argue with
funny it shows that you're confident
your tit you're not taking yourself so
super seriously and you'll probably get
them to laugh because humor cuts through
a lot of BS especially the BS world of
leftist politics I would go bold I would
be funny about it that's it's actually
kind of the way that guys should
approach girls you're gonna either
approach girl kind of creepy and timid
and weird and earnest but I really like
you and please serve as a bunch of
flowers do you like me or you can kind
of joke about and say hey you're really
cute let's go get a drink tonight what
was that oh I think you're cute and
therefore I would like to get a drink
with you tonight would you like to go
get a drink
it's kind of funny it's a light it's not
making a big deal out of it that that's
what I would do in politics and and
romance and in the you know look in
these days where I find politics very
romantic anyway and conservatives are
much more romantic in their politics
than the left which is eggheads and dour
doer and and upset all the time go for
that be a bold conservative from surreal
mr. Noles I'm a Democrat and love your
show thank you that's very kind my
mother is a Democrat as well and grew up
in the 40s and 50s and she said she
expected races she experienced racism
then and she makes it clear it is not
what we are experiencing now
I don't think President Trump and others
are racist but the media say that he is
has the definition of racism changed
well the left has not only tried to
change the definition of racism they've
tried to change the definition of all
sorts of words they've changed the
definition of justice too not justice
right it used to be justice getting what
you deserve with that favor now we have
their version of justice social justice
economic justice reproductive justice
but broadly all their new definitions of
justice means getting what you don't
deserve
because you are favored that's the
inversion of political correctness I
mean the politically correct left has
redefined man to mean not a man now a
man means woman woman means man totally
backwards and they've done this with
racism as well so they'll say if a why
person doesn't discriminate against
black people he is a racist even though
he's the opposite of a racist they say
because he is white he is by definition
a racist there have been this has been
written about in academic literature
from the left and yet they'll say if a
black person despises white people just
on the basis of their skin call them the
white Devils that person is not a racist
even though he holds racially bigoted
views he can't be a racist because he is
black because black people are somehow I
guess they're incapable of the same kind
of things that we would expect of other
people that's the racially bigoted view
of the left it's exactly flipping that
word I'm not surprised I'm glad to hear
that I've got at least one Democrat
listener to the show but I'm not
surprised I suspect they're actually a
lot of Democrat listeners to the show
why B not because we agree on everything
we probably don't agree on everything
but because this approach from the left
of demonizing half of your countrymen is
deplorable and you're redeemable and
saying the people who are not bigots are
bigots and people who are bigots are not
biggest and saying it up is down and
left his right and men and women is so
offensive to people because you're just
being lied to
you're being told by the left and
increasingly because the left took over
the Democratic Party by the democratic
party you're being told don't believe
your eyes believe what I'm telling you
don't believe what you see yourself
don't think for yourself just repeat
what I say and I think it's turned off a
lot of people I think it helped yet
President Trump elected and I think it's
the reason that a fair number of
Democrats and centrists and left wingers
listened to conservative shows because
at least we're talking about the issues
and trying to work them out as best we
can and not just regurgitating BS
inverted politically correct lies from
Joshua Michael I know you've mentioned
you were in acting and with that line of
work you must be able to memorize many
lines for your performance my question
is what methods do you use to remember a
vast amount of lines for your
performances or are you one of those
people that can remember almost anything
after reading it once thanks for
everything you do and the daily wire
group there are different ways to
memorize if you want to memorize
something and have it in your head for
the next
our you can train yourself to do that I
can do that for instance I can look at a
sheet of paper
pretty much just once and have it
memorized for the next hour and then I'm
gonna forget it if you want to memorize
something and have it with you for 10
years or 20 years I mean there are
monologues the poems Shakespeare Dante
all these sort of things that I
memorized when I was 16 years old but I
can still remember word perfectly and
the reason is because of that technique
if you really want to get something
memorized is you have to say it out loud
and you have to not just read it in your
head and try to remember it say it out
loud and use your muscles in an
exaggerated way so if I were trying to
memorize I don't know a Robert Frost
poem two roads diverged in a yellow wood
and sorry I could not travel both and be
one traveler long I stood on and on and
on I wouldn't just even say it like that
I would make my mouth really big and I
would use all my muscles say two roads
diverged in a yellow wood and sorry I
could on and on and the reason I would
do that is because of muscle memory so
you're when you memorize in that way
you'd kind of remember how your mouth
moves you kind of remember how your your
speech is physically and it helps you to
remember the lines this is important
advice not just in memorizing a script
or a speech or a presentation it's
important advice for life because what
it tells you is the importance of habit
we think of virtue is doing one good
thing one time that's not what that's
not what virtue is virtue is a habit you
train in it it's a discipline you come
if you practice and the virtues long
enough they become habitual if you
practice sin and vice long enough that
becomes habitual too and then it becomes
addiction the same is true of virtue and
so you've got to put it into your body
straw politics you can't just think
about politics you can't just
pontificate and talk about your
imaginary abstract world you got to do
it you got to be in the fight you've got
to have the strenuous life you've got to
actually put it in your body we're in
the real world we're not just floating
brains in the abstract we got real
bodies we're living in time and space
and you have to do you have to act all
right one more question and we're at
Michael happy 400 show another 400 more
your mouth to God's ears my question
relates to
politics in the workplace lately my
company has been pushing for all
employees to go to a climate change
March for obvious reasons this sounds
like a terrible idea I'm extremely
worried about getting fired for being
conservative and have been tight-lipped
about other issues at work besides
showing up to the March with I hate AOC
signs how would you handle the situation
obviously in my current line of work I'm
pretty open about my political views but
I have been an actor as we just talked
about in the last question I've worked
in in other places where I've been a
little quieter about my political views
because if you open up about your
political views you don't work and
that's look that's a choice you're gonna
make I've made that choice now but when
if you want to work in something and you
know that your political views are gonna
get you fired for it sometimes you need
to be a little bit cleverer about it I
certainly would not go to the March I
wouldn't violate your beliefs and your
views and your vision of morality
however you don't need to walk in and
have like to ar-15s in your hand and say
I America baby I love Trump coo coo coo
coo coo you don't need to do that you
can be a little clever you can be a
little sly about it what I would do is
make some plans on the day of that
climate March and then when they say
you're gonna come to the climate March
you say oh I already have plans I got to
go to my sister's lunch or whatever
whatever plans you make that way you're
not lying you're not violating your
moral principles and you live to fight
another day at your job and then when
the time comes for you to really make
that difference you'll be able to do it
as long as you make sure you don't
violate what your beliefs and you stay
true and you keep integrity all right
that's our show we have another show
tomorrow because we skipped the show
yesterday so in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
see you then
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy bori our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer Mathis Glover
technical producer
Austin Stephens editor Dany D'Amico our
audio mixer is Mike Cora Mina hair and
makeup by Jesuit Elvira production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 hey everyone
I'm Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show it's summertime the livin is
easy and the news is slow which means
it's a great time to stop look around
and see if we can tell the difference
between what's really happening in our
country and what the media wants us to
believe is happening those are not at
all the same things we'll talk about it
on the Andrew Clavin